there are serious questions tonight
about whether Nancy Pelosi back here in
DC will be Speaker of the House when
Democrats take over the chamber next
year
Pelosi does not yet have a visible
challenger most expect her to get the
gavel again but Pelosi does have a group
of Democrats firmly against her return
to the top spot chief congressional
correspondent Mike Emanuel looks at both
sides tonight from Capitol Hill I intend
to win the speakership with Democratic
votes but there are signs it certainly
won't be easy Fox's confirmed at least
17 Democrats some incumbents others
newly elected have signed on to a letter
saying they won't support Pelosi for
speaker Pelosi hinted at sexism noting
14 are men I enjoy a tremendous amount
of support from the women in our caucus
from the new members who are women in
our caucus and so I get the upside I
think of being a woman you'd have to ask
them if in fact there is any misogyny
involved in it it's their problem not
mine
then there's Ohio's Marcia fudge who has
openly said she's considering running
for speaker - she is the kind of new
leader that we need in this party she's
incredible that's exactly the kind of
leader that I want to see as our next
speaker New York Republican Tom Reid
says he's considering backing Pelosi if
she endorses some changes in rules that
would reduce leadership c-can't role of
the agenda on the House floor
if Pelosi finds a way to round up the
votes her colleagues note she'll have
the challenge of leading a spirited
group of freshmen we've got to make sure
that we have got processes in place in
the caucus that the voices are heard and
they are vocal congresswoman elect
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes participated in
a protest in Pelosi's office on her
first day of orientation she's pushing
for a green new deal and wants to work
toward the goal of 100 percent renewable
energy other Democrats are pushing for
medicare-for-all which could cost thirty
two point six trillion dollars over ten
years according to a George Mason
University study and there are those
including a likely Committee Chair who
have called for impeaching President
Trump
you remember the House GOP leadership
says keeping Democrats unified is not
going to be easy I'm sure that Minority
Leader Pelosi likes the new energy
that's coming in the problem is most of
that energy happens to be socialist so
that's certainly not a recipe for
success for the nation or certainly for
her party so far the only member of
Democratic leadership with a declared
challenger in South Carolina Congressman
Jim Clyburn some African American
members are taking offense noting no one
has officially stepped up to challenge
Pelosi or whip Steny Hoyer some
Democrats predict it is going to get
ugly
Brett will see Mike Emanuel live on the
hill Mike thanks